hi sorry I'm late
hi Joe Joanna nice to meet you look hard
seriously this guy just hand me his
business card this is the 19th century I
mean we all have smartphones in our
pockets why are we handing over
rectangular pieces of paper you know why
because the attempts to kill the
business card have been highly
unsuccessful some have tried to replace
them all together with smartphones
others have actually put chips inside
the cards themselves but still the most
useful tech for business cards means
actually being surrounded by paper bump
was one of the major players that tried
to get us to transfer info by tapping
our phones if two phones had the app you
could just tap them together and they
magically transmit your contact
information through a combination of
wireless tech and the physical bumping
of the phone but Google bought bump and
shut it down last week Google also as an
Android feature called beam that lets
you use wireless technology called
near-field communication or NFC but it
only works Android to Android and even
if it was multi-platform iPhones don't
yet have NFC what's needed is an app
that's immensely popular across all
smartphone platforms like a Yelp or
Pandora for the business card exchange
you don't only need people with the same
smartphones as us unless you're at these
guys enter Evernote the popular
note-taking service which launched the
Evernote Hello app using audio tones it
transfers info to users who are in close
proximity to each other it works quite
well but its flaws that it's buried in
the app and there are still too many
steps far more than the old business
card handoff so they can't kill business
cards people are thinking why not make
them more smartphone friendly yes some
companies have put QR codes on cards but
I'm not sure anyone really knows how to
use those
some companies have announced plans to
put NFC tags into cards though the cards
are really pricey and again only Android
or Windows phones can read those that's
where a startup called touch based
contacts is trying to do something
different
they've made a card with conductive ink
so you can physically tap the card on
the phone and then boom it brings up
your contact information it does require
an app but it's pretty awesome and you
can store lots of information within
your profile it's in the early stages
though it'll be limited to iPhones at
first and they haven't quite sorted out
yet how you'll be able to sync it with
your phone's address book but the
problem with these options is that they
require special cards so even if you
adopt them chances are other people
won't have caught on so for now and for
the foreseeable future the best way to
kill off these non digital cards is to
scan them sure you could buy a business
card scanner for $100 or more or you
could just use the scanner that's
already in your pocket your smartphone
LinkedIn's free app called card munch
has you send photos to a human-powered
service to be transcribed it took a
while when I tried it - over 6 hours
just for 2 cards
Evernote's hello app is much quicker
just snap a photo and the contact info
is transcribed within seconds the
catches Evernote thinks we should pay $5
per month or a yearly fee of $45 for
unlimited business card scanning if you
don't pay you only get five scans per
month that's it only five people you can
meet every month the best choice I've
found is Kam card for a one-time $3.00
fee the app gives you unlimited business
card scanning it's fast and when people
are scanned you can send them your own
digital business card and return yes
it's 2014 and I'm about to accept this
guy's business card I find it a little
hard to believe that one day we won't be
using smart phones or some sort of
wearable chip to exchange information
but for now this is the best we're gonna
do thank you here's mine